have you guys seen any like obscure
sport that you like that you've only
you only know about because it's been
recommended on youtube or something but
then like it actually looks pretty
[ __ ] hype
there was one i forgot what it was but i
think it's like an indian sport or a
southeast asian sport where it's
volleyball
but you kick the ball what the [ __ ] is
it
wait what i've seen
yes it's literally just think of
volleyball but like you know how
volatile you pass it with your hands
yeah but instead of your hands you
kick it it's not just football tennis
kind of don't say that
every sibling like players like how gay
how did you ruin the sanctity of our
spawn so that sounds good like
have you seen stuff like professional
tag and stuff like really
[ __ ] awesome like vox did a video
about how it came to be as well how do
you think
how did they come just a guy who was
like really obsessed with the idea
of making like tag courses just kept
like building them
and people were like yeah this is pretty
fun actually you know what's one excuse
what i really enjoy watching ultimate
frisbee
yeah ultimate yeah that's a really
[ __ ] that's really fun
well in the us i think it's quite
popular because like marcus brownlee
right plays it
oh really yeah he plays it is it an
olympic sport it's not is it no no no
it's not olympic sports he mentioned it
quite a lot though in his videos and
he shared videos of him playing it yeah
i guess outside of america it's not
really like a thing i mean i remember
we played it for like sports once for
school and it was really fun yeah i mean
we we played in school as well
so it was definitely a thing but it was
more seen of just as just it sounds like
the most college sport ever
yeah you know what i mean
[Music]
yeah what if they called it like epic
frisbee
i'd be playing it right now yeah i'd
like to join our epic frisbee team
that's the kind of sports you you'd
think you'd see on twitch or something
right
frisbee i could see ultimate frisbee on
twitch
that'd be [ __ ] awesome like prov like
you're a frisbee pov you're an ultimate
frisbee yeah i mean i i feel like twitch
would be the perfect platform for a lot
of these more obscure sports like
professional arm wrestling as well have
you seen that
that's like the most dude bro sport i've
ever seen right that's like the slapping
slap moist critical love to
commentate on like what i love what i
love about watching professional
uh professional arm wrestling is is it
is that like
they're egging each other on to do
better right it's
it's almost like it's almost like a gym
session was like you got this bro
no no you got this bro ah actually
you know the best one is i decided this
is the best one the best
sport you've seen on the internet three
times forget about but remember it's
badass yeah
it's the like sumo but with the like the
the like robot wars
oh yeah yeah yeah like sumo it's a sumo
ring with like where they have like mini
robots and they have to push each other
out and it's from where the on my own
oh that really popular edit where like
it's such a good video play a gif
oh my god
yeah it's like the what was that show
it's in japan robot wars i think
no but um america did a version of it
i think that clip is from a japanese
it's from the japanese one where they do
it with miniature ones because the
battle bots and robot wars in the uk
were like [ __ ]
giant yeah yeah like these ones are like
tabletop well
yeah it's something to destroy it's
supposed to push the other thing out
that's really cool really [ __ ] cool
there's nothing getting destroyed i am
not interested
my man monkey brain not happy no
destruction